Multicolor variegated or space dyed yarns,
whatever you call them, these yarns can be
challenging for those who are fussy about
the colors, pooling or flashing when
knitting.
Pooling can be especially problematic for
machine knitters because the tension on
our machines doesn't change
while we're knitting a piece.
Hand knitters naturally very the tension
as they knit, so the pooling may not be as
noticeable.
This worsted weight.
Yarn has very short color repeats.
The color changes every
six to eight inches.
The swatch shows this pooling
in this particular yard.
Can you see the diagonal line between the
purples on the left and the blues on the
right?
Machine dyed yarns or space dyed are more
predictable because the color is laid down
in very specific lengths.
Hand dyed yarns are not dyed with
precision, so pooling may be reduced.
Now you can't just look at a cone or a
Hank of yarn and predict how the colors
will knit.
You must swatch.
And you need to swatch at different widths
to get an idea of how the knitting will
look before you start your project.
Think of how wide the back of
a sweater is versus the sleeve.
Now you might like the look of this
patterning, and especially if you get a
nice zigzag pattern on your knitting.
But keep in mind that this is just a
swatch that measures about seven inches.
The patterning would be very
different over a larger area.
Here's some ways to
tame the color pooling.
Try knitting every other row
with a different ball of yarn.
Now, depending on the colorway, you
might also wind one of the balls from the
opposite end to reverse
the color sequence.
This mixes up your colors really nicely.
For machine knitters,
try varying your tension.
For example, knit two or three
rows at the main tension.
Then switch to your main tension
minus one for a couple of rows.
Go back to your main tension.
Then switched to main tension plus one
for a couple of rows, alternating the
tensions.
Of course, you'll want to swatch using
this technique for accurate gauge, but it
can help mix up the colors and prevent
pooling.
Here's another idea.
Choose one of the colors in the color way
and alternate the variegated with a solid,
or use a contrasting color, maybe
black for the alternate color.
What if you want the color arrangement of
a variegated yarn to be exactly the same
on the sleeves that are narrow
as it is on the wider back piece.
Use cut 'n sew you'll knit some
fabric, the width of your widest piece.
Then cut out your Garment
pieces as if you were sewing.
Now this takes some planning and it's
going to use a whole lot more yarn, but
with this method, you could ensure that
both of the fronts had the same color
patterning, for example,
and the using this method, knitting fabric
for machine knitters is fast and easy.
Don't let color pooling or flashing of
variegated yarns stop you from enjoying
the beautiful variety
of this class of yarns.
Thank you for watching.
The Knit it Now Learning Library has
hundreds of tutorials that will help you
be a better knitter.
Please subscribe and join the Knit
it Now Community happy knitting.